[Music]  my mother you are brave and strong and  smart and you have taught me that you  can be kind  oh no you guys got off easy honestly  oh really often that was nothing that  was the class II for Shelley it was a  big night for The Handmaid's Tale at the  2017 Emmy Awards Elisabeth Moss nabbing  her first Emmy win after eight  nominations there were so many times  people thought you should have gotten  the hemming already for madman's and how  does it feel to be taking this I a me  home tonight I mean it's wonderful and  all of all of that was wonderful as well  you know it's it's it's not up to me  really I just try to do the best work  possible and hope people watch it so the  fact that it's for this show obviously  I'm incredibly proud of it personally so  it does mean a lot to me  [Music]  [Music]